it's a bit of an irony to being here
because on one hand it's beautiful and
peaceful and serene but you're actually
at the eye of the storm when it comes to
the war on rhino right zooming over to
always a very very special part of this
particular auction is of course Toronto
and away we go
two hundred nanometer to an over 200 our
way zero 170 if the economy out here is
driven by big-game hunting and Safari
tourism there are some rare instances of
rhino hunting but mostly tourists just
want to take photos and to keep their
reserves stocked with rhinos ranchers
sometimes buy and sell them at auction I
know all done I think that deserves a
big hand well done so you bought it
right now today yeah the one on the
right feels weird right to distill this
majestic beast down into like dollars
and cents but you also can't pretend
like we exist in a vacuum where that
doesn't have it for a variety of reasons
rhinos are really expensive to care for
and outside of tourism ranchers don't
have a good way of making that money
back you're sort of expecting people to
put in a huge amount of money and
where's our money coming from you've got
guys who are storing horn in the hope
that it will legalize one day and then
hopefully be able to cash in and recover
cost are you pro legalization I am
actually yeah it's the same as the drug
trade the debate in South Africa right
now is whether to give in to the demand
for horn which again is based entirely
on the myth and legalize its trade on
the global market pro-legalization
ranchers claimed that because rhino horn
grows back when it's trimmed it could be
a renewable resource the theory goes if
you flood the market with legal horn it
would drive down the black market price
if you do that you reduce the incentive
to poach and thereby make rhinos a much
more attractive animal to keep
but as the legalization debate his wage
in policy arenas right now ranchers on
the ground have a serious poaching
problem
to protect their animals they're
tracking down all of the rhinos on their
ranches tranquilizing them and shearing
down their horns to Nub's
with a chainsaw
[Applause]
who would take a chainsaw to an animal
in their right mind but it's what we
have to do to keep him alive
[Music]
you